now tonight we're continuing to see the
devastating consequences of biden and
harris's border neglect
as illegal immigrant migrants continue
to pour across the southern border and
it's getting worse day by day
ask yourself if the biden harris
administration really cared about
containing covid
why are they embracing open borders are
migrants being asked to show their proof
of vaccine as they walk across the
border
are migrants being required to show
proof of a negative test
and now biden's department of justice is
suing texas
for having the audacity to want to
secure
the state and wanting to do the job that
the federal government is refusing to do
and attorney general ken paxton
responded in a statement in part
quote texas won't back down i will
defend governor abbott's order
in court and we will work together to
keep president bidens
out of texas's business and attorney
general
paxton he joins us now mr attorney
general thank you so much
the the crisis there on in texas and
across the southern border
re the numbers are so stunning and we
see this video and people
are literally just streaming across but
so many of them have coveted evidently
yeah you know it's ironic too if you're
a us citizen and you're coming from
another country you can't get back in if
you have coven
but if you're coming here illegally you
can come across without any testing and
you can walk across the border
and and they will send you somewhere in
the country so this
this expansion of covet is not just for
texans it's going to go all over the
country
well explain to us they come across they
just let them in the door
don't test for covid but what are these
people supposed to do for
food shelter a job i mean they have no
documents there's no paperwork
and yet they just tacitly opened the
door literally i mean you watch that
video
next to us they are literally just
opening or saying hey come on in
yeah jason that is a really good
question i've been to many of these
detention centers where they're
they're holding these people and they do
not ever tell us
where these people are going and how
long they're staying
they're just transported secrets
secretly
the media isn't told we're not told
other states aren't told
this is all being done quietly the media
doesn't complain about it
and we have no idea where these people
are going with cobit and with
some of the other problems that they
take with them
and my understanding is some of them are
they're bypassing the tsa
requirements of showing identification
doing what
again ordinary citizens have to do they
don't have to do
it's easier for them no
it's unconscionable and what's amazing
is that the cartels are the ones helping
these people
come here every one of these people just
about every one of these people
has to pay the cartel to get across the
board that's the only way you can get
across
and they also are importing more drugs
as a result there's more human
trafficking along our border there's
more
property crime crimes there's all kinds
of crime associated with this
and the biden administration is suing us
because our governor is willing to step
up and try to stop
some of these harms that the federal
government is not just they're
basically turning their head to their
they're inviting it in
yeah well good luck with that uh that
suit we'll be watching it closely
attorney general for texas ken paxton
thank you so much for joining us tonight
on hannity hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else